- So thank you so much Jeanne
for that kind introduction.
As Jeanne said, my name is Joe
and I am a graduate student
in Rockefeller University.
So here's just a brief outline
of what I'm gonna do today.
I'm gonna take you through
what I'm talking about
and why I think it's important
and then give you some background
which is important for
understanding the paper today
by talking about immune memory
before we dive into the paper itself
and talk about what the authors
did in this particular paper
and what they showed
and what questions I
think remain outstanding
in this field.
But before I do that a little
bit more about who I am.
So this is a picture of Joe the scientist.
As I was introduced, I'm a
third year graduate student
at Rockefeller University.
I work in a field called biophysics,
which you could really
think of as the interface
between biology and physics;
the physics governing
the biological molecules
in your body.
And I moved to United States
six years ago from London
where I grew up and I was born.
Cool, I'm not only a
scientist, as was alluded to,
this is a picture of me from,
this Christmas actually where
I was hiking a mountain,
which is one of the things
that I really liked doing,
skiing, backpacking,
being in the outdoors.
Okay but enough about me.
Let's talk about what I'm
gonna talk to you about today.
So what am I talking about and why?
So this is the paper that
I'm presenting to you today,
it's called, "Lack of Reinfection
"in Rhesus Macaques
Infected with SARS-CoV-2."
And as was discussed prior to me starting,
this is a pre-print,
which means it's not been
certified by peer review.
I'm just gonna take you
through a little bit more
about what that means
and elaborate on what Petro and Jeanie
was saying at the beginning.
Basically how science is done,
if you start out on the left here,
you can see that scientists
collect scientific data,
obviously, and we write it up in a report
and that report, usually is
evaluated by other scientists
in this process called peer review
where they give us feedback,
tell us experiments,
maybe extra experiments that we should do,
caveats we should include,
et cetera, et cetera.
And there's a feedback loop there.
And then the end product after that,
of that peer reviewed report
is hopefully published
and hopefully has an impact,
a positive impact on society.
This process of peer review
though, can take some time,
in fact, in some cases it can
take up to a year or more.
And that's one of the things
that's currently a bit
of a problem in science
and especially in the
context of a pandemic
where we want policymakers
and the general public
to have up to date information
as quickly as possible,
this process of publishing
material immediately online
is really useful and
that's what a pre-print is.
For those of you who have been following
the styles of scientific reasoning
in these series of talks,
today I'm gonna be talking about
an experimental evaluation,
where we're using data to test hypotheses
and get to an answer as a result of that.
So why am I talking about this?
Well, the first reason of course,
is that there's considerable
interest to people
who have had COVID-19
because they want to understand
their own personal risk going forward,
is it possible for me to get sick again?
And that will set to rest
many fears that people have
or cause people to behave
differently, possibly.
But more important is,
it's got profound public
health ramifications.
And that's because
depending on how regularly
people can be reinfected by a virus,
different control measures
and strategies are
going to be appropriate.
And that's because if
people are susceptible
to being infected again,
shortly after being infected,
it means we're gonna
have to think differently
about vaccination,
it means we're gonna
have to think differently
about social distancing and
other public health measures.
One final thing before we start talking
about the background to this paper
is that what I'm talking about today
is research done on monkeys
and that deserves acknowledgement.
Whenever scientists work with animals,
we think about three big things,
what we call the three Rs.
The principle's to reduce
the number of animals
used in our experiments,
refine our experiments
to maximize the wellbeing
of the animals in the experiments
and wherever we can replace
animals with other systems,
be they computational systems
or other systems like
cells in a Petri dish,
and also to replace more
sophisticated animals
with less sophisticated animals.
We'd rather do experiments
on flies than on monkeys.
But in some cases, as with this paper,
it's important that we do this work
and we need to understand
as close to relative
to humans as possible.
There are lots of organizations involved
in thinking about these ethical concerns
and monitoring how we use these organisms.
And I've just listed some of them here.
They are, the university
itself, government regulators
and professional organizations,
which certify them.
And this paper comes from a lab
which is certified these organizations,
and that's the gold standard
in scientific animal care.
Okay, so before we talk about the paper,
we need to talk a little bit
about how immune memory works.
And this is not really news to any of you
because all of you will know
from your own experience
that your immune system
remembers past infections
and stops you getting
sick for a second time.
What I think of when I think of this
is how relatively
unconcerned my parents were
when I got chicken pox, right?
Because adults know, who had
chickenpox when they were kids,
that they're really
unlikely to get it again
from their children,
their immune system has
remembered the virus
that causes chicken pox
and makes them very unlikely,
inoculates and protects them
against getting sick a second time.
It's also obviously the
basis of vaccination.
When we vaccinate people,
what we're doing is we're
introducing a modified,
weakened strain of a virus or pathogen
or we're introducing a
fragment of that pathogen
to cause the immune system to remember it
so that when you see it
in the flesh for real,
your immune system
prevents you getting sick
because it's remembered the pathogen
or remembered the mock
version of the pathogen.
So what's going on under the hood here?
How is your immune system
remembering things?
Well, it's helpful to break
the immune system down
into the two branches of it.
So we have what's called
innate immunity in humans
and we have also what's
called adaptive immunity.
And innate immunity is a
general rapid response,
which even starts before you
are infected with a pathogen.
It's all the defenses like your skin
and mucus in your respiratory tract
that stop you being exposed to
pathogens in the first place
as well as general defenses
when you get hit by a pathogen.
Adaptive immunity is
slower and it's specific
and it involves the production
of specialized antibodies
and specialized immune cells.
And I'm gonna talk more
about what those immune cells
and antibodies are.
But this is the branch
of the immune system,
which is able to remember things.
And so when we talk about immune memory,
we're talking about the
adaptive immune system
and we're talking about
a very specific memory
of a very particular pathogen.
So how does it work?
Well, what happens is a pathogen
such as a virus infects us,
we have a process going on
inside the immune system
where we learn the
identity of that pathogen.
And then we produce specialized molecules
known as antibodies that proteins
and we produce specialized
cells which make those proteins
and do other things to
help us become immune.
And those molecules and
those proteins are present,
and help us clear the infection
and they also are present going forward
to help us protect against the
same infection in the future.
These are the three key players.
We've got antibodies, we have
B cells which make antibodies,
and T-cells, which help B
cells to make antibodies
and do a whole load of other things.
And obviously many a PhD thesis
has been written about
any one of these things.
So I can't really take you
through them in detail,
but I just want to give
you an overall outline
of what's going on.
So antibodies work by being sticky
and I've highlighted
the bits of the antibody
which are sticky, I've just
circled them in white here.
And really you can think about
them working in in two ways,
they work in lots of ways,
but two really important ways they work
is by sticking to a virus or
a pathogen inside your body
and sort of waving to the
rest of the immune system,
"over here, over here,
I've stuck the bugger.
"You can come and get him. "
And they also work by sort
of gumming things up, right?
If you're a virus and you get
stuck all over by an antibody,
you can imagine it's not really very easy
for you to move around,
for you to do what you wanna do
to interact with the players
you need to interact with
inside the body to cause an infection.
And B cells are obviously
gonna make the antibodies
and T cells are gonna
support them in that role.
And they are also very specific.
The bits I've circled on
the T cell and the B cell,
like the antibody, are sticky
and they're sticky only in a specific way.
So an antibody that's sticky
against the measles virus
will not be sticky against
a different virus like flu.
And that's really important,
it's a specific response.
So what happens when
you remember something?
Well, we can think of it
a little bit like this,
so along the bottom here, I'm
just plotting advancing time.
And initially what
happens in my example here
is you get infected on the
left, there's a blue arrow.
And your immune system takes
some time to respond to that,
your adaptive immune system.
You could think of it as it's
finding the right antibody,
it's calibrating a response.
It's figuring out the best
way to clear this virus,
this pathogen away.
And so this is time that elapses
and during that time you're
feeling unwell, right?
Because the pathogen is
running wild, is infecting you,
and that's what being sick is.
So then you make your antibodies,
you make your B cells,
you make your T cells
and those help you clear
the infection away.
And then subsequently if you
get reinfected with the virus,
your immune system reuses the same cells
and the same antibodies
it made the first time.
There's no point reinventing the wheel,
it's already done this before.
It knows how to get rid of
this particular pathogen,
the correct antibodies,
the correct B cells,
the correct T cells to use.
And as a result, it's able
to deploy them very quickly
to help clear the infection away.
But your immune system is
actually even clever than that
because it doesn't just
use the same things again,
it uses the same things
again in a more strong
and extensive way.
So if we plot, again here,
I'm plotting time along the bottom here
and I'm plotting going up the side,
the strength of response.
After the first infection
you have a weaker response
that occurs after a larger period of time.
Whereas after the second exposure,
you have a stronger response
that occurs after a
shorter period of time.
So your immune system is reusing the cells
and the molecules it
generated the first time
and it's deploying them harder
and faster to help you beat
the pathogen more quickly
and prevent you going through
that period of getting sick.
Okay, so can I bring this to life?
How can I make this a
bit clearer to you guys?
Well, I have an example or
something of an illustration.
So if you'll indulge me for a moment,
I have a problem for you.
and the problem is this;
Maria went to the bread store
to buy a loaf of bread for dinner.
She had two quarters, four dimes,
three nickels and two pennies.
And the total cost of
the bread with 82 cents.
She promised to make sure
she had exactly one coin
remaining after the purchase.
So the question I'm setting for you is
which coin did she have left
after buying the loaf of bread?
And I think Jeanie is gonna set that up
so you should be able to
answer that question now.
I'll give you a few moments.
The votes are trickling in,
we've got about 20 of you so far.
Give you a little bit longer.
- We forgot to warn people
to bring their scratch paper to the talk.
- They're getting there,
people are getting there.
- [Jeanie] Yeah.
Okay, cool, I think
we'll leave it at that,
I've given you a minute.
So what we can see is you did
get the answer right, overall.
It is a quarter, that's
the coin she had left over.
Great, I'm really glad you did.
Now I have another problem for you.
Another question for you.
Maria went to the bread store
to buy a loaf of bread for dinner.
She had two quarters, four dimes,
three nickels and two pennies.
And the total cost of
the bread was 82 cents.
She promised to make sure
she had exactly one coin
remaining after the purchase,
which coin is she has
left after the purchase?
And I'm not actually
gonna ask you to do this
because, hopefully you've noticed
that it's the same question.
So hopefully if I was
to ask you to do this,
you would just remember
that you'd solved it
and you wouldn't have to
recalculate the same problem.
And that's a little bit
like what your immune system is doing.
So I sent you this math problem
and I give you this period
of time to work it out,
you have to get your calculator out,
pull your solution together
and then you answer me.
And then I ask you the
same question a bit later
and you don't need time
to work it out again
'cause you just remember,
I've already done this,
the answer is a quarter.
What are you doing, Joe?
So that's what your immune
system does in a way.
It has it's first infection,
and it's spending this time figuring out
how to fight the infection.
And then it comes up with a good response
with a specific antibody
that will target that
particular infection.
And then if you re-exposed
it the second time
to the same pathogenic again,
it's not gonna rework out
how to fight that pathogen.
It's just gonna reuse
it's solution from before
and deploy that response harder and faster
as we saw before, and
prevent you from getting sick
and clear the infection really quickly.
Okay, so we've said
that your immune system
remembers past infections
to stop you getting sick
for a second time.
And we said that it's
the basis of vaccination.
But memory is a funny thing.
And I'm thinking about my
own memory when I say that.
Because we remember some
things very, very well,
perfectly even though they
occurred a very long time ago.
So this is me on my first
day of secondary school
with my two brothers.
I think one of them is on, so
thank you for joining Zack.
But I'm the one on the left,
you can tell I have dimples,
the other two do not.
But the point of putting this here
is I remember this day really well.
I remember how I felt, I
remember feeling nervous,
I remember meeting my
teacher for the first time,
the walk to school,
meeting people who are
gonna become my friends.
And it viscerally quite
burned into my brain.
This is not a day I'm gonna forget.
On the other hand, there are some things
that we do very often
that we don't remember
all that well at all.
And so here is a picture from my phone
of the instructions as
to how to open my mailbox
at the university,
turn left a certain number of times
and then write to set the number of times,
it's actually a very
difficult thing to do.
But the point is, I've done
this dozens and dozens of times
and I don't remember it.
Every time I wanna open my mailbox,
I pull out my phone and
I look at the picture
because I don't remember how
to do it without that prompt.
So your immune system isn't
very different than this,
in the sense that it can
remember some things very well
and other things much less well.
So the question really is is
COVID-19 like my mailbox code
or is it like my first day of school?
Is it something that your immune
system remembers very well
or is it something
that your immune system
remembers really poorly,
or is it somewhere in between?
That's not a binary, there's
a continuum of options
between being remembered
really well or not really well.
And if we look at other pathogens,
we can see that your
immune system is exhibiting
this continuum of memory.
So a pathogen like measles,
the measles virus is actually
extremely well remembered
by your immune system.
So if you get infected with measles,
your immune system will
generate a response
and that response, that specific
response will be remembered
for decades and decades.
And it's why measles
is a very good disease
to vaccinate people against.
You vaccinate them as children
and they have immunity lasting
for decades and decades
going forward from that point.
And in fact, if you ask an immunologist
to estimate how long the memory,
the immune memory of measles lasts,
they might tell you up to 200 years.
So this is an extremely good memory
that your immune system
generates of measles
and it's why you get vaccinated
only at the beginning of your childhood
and you don't need to see the virus again
to be immune from it.
Tetanus is a bacteria that
causes infections in people.
And many of you may have
had multiple tetanus shots
over your life.
In fact, it's quite common
to have tetanus boosters
every 10 years or so.
Because whilst your immune system
is pretty good at remembering tetanus,
it does need periodic reminders
and that's what those boosters serve as,
to prevent you forgetting tetanus.
So tetanus, we could put
somewhere in between a measles
and the last disease I'm gonna talk about,
which is just the common cold.
Now I should say that the common cold
is actually quite a complicated collection
of different diseases.
It's actually caused by
many different viruses.
But each one of those viruses
is actually pretty poorly
remembered by your immune system.
And that's not that surprising
because we know from
experience that we get colds
year after year after year after year.
It's not like being a
senior citizen protects you
against getting a cold.
Unfortunately, people
throughout their entire life
get sick with colds.
And that's because your immune system
is not remembering this pathogen.
So it can't reuse the
response it used last time,
it has to start from scratch every time.
And as a result, you get sick.
Because you have that delayed period
where your immune system is figuring out
how to get rid of the disease.
So where does COVID-19
fit on this continuum?
Is it closer to the common cold end,
the measles end or
somewhere in the middle?
And that's really the problem
that these authors in this
paper try to shed some light.
Okay, so enough background,
let's dive into actually
what's done in this paper
and what's really going on.
So what do the authors do in this paper?
I'm gonna take you through.
So what they're doing is they
start off on the left here
with some monkeys,
and what they do is
they initially challenge
or expose those monkeys to SARS-CoV-2
the virus that causes COVID-19.
And you can see the days being counted off
on the bottom here, from
that period on the left.
And I'm gonna take you
through the rest of it,
but just you can see the days
and I've given you an indication
that DPI stands for Days
Post Initial Infection
and DPR stands for Days Post reinfection.
That second number will
make more sense in a moment.
So we've initially challenged
or exposed the monkeys to the virus
and then we're gonna monitor
them to see if they get sick,
which they should because we've
exposed them to this virus,
but also make sure that they get better.
So we want them to experience
the disease and then recover.
Then we're gonna take a
subset of those monkeys
and we're gonna re-challenge them
or re-expose them to the
same virus, SARS-CoV-2.
And then basically just ask
did the monkeys get sick?
Because if they got sick
then it suggests that their immune system
didn't remember the virus.
And if they didn't get sick
then it suggests that their immune system
did remember the virus.
Okay, so that's in broad brush strokes
what the authors have done here.
But how do you do that?
How do you go about
monitoring these things?
What's the matter of
being sick or not sick?
Well, there's a few different measures
that the authors are gonna use.
The first one is swabs,
and this is gonna be familiar to you
because people all over
the world who are concerned
that they have COVID
are going into hospitals
and getting swabs.
And then what we do is we look for,
scientists look for the presence
of the virus on that swab.
And that's exactly what
the authors have done here
with the monkeys.
There's a periodic
sampling of the monkeys,
where they're being swamped
to basically monitor,
to look for, can we
find virus in the monkey
after we initially infect it,
after we tried to reinfect it,
and when it's sick and
when it's recovered.
So that's one thing we're gonna do.
Number two, we're going
to look for antibodies.
Now, I told you that antibodies
are these sticky proteins
that your body produces in
response to a specific pathogen.
So here we're gonna be looking
for specific antibodies,
Abs is short for antibodies.
Specific antibodies that
respond to the SARS-CoV-2 virus.
And we're gonna look for them
after we've challenged
the monkeys initially
and then after they've been re-challenged
with this infection.
So those are gonna
report on what's going on
in the monkey's blood with antibodies
and what's going on with the virus
but how do we know if the
monkey is actually sick?
Well, we can use the same things
that we would use on people.
We can use x-rays.
So we can take pictures
of the monkeys' lungs
to see whether they look healthy
or whether they don't look healthy.
And chest x-rays are
gonna be used by doctors,
they are used by doctors
all over the world
to look inside your lungs to
see do you have pneumonia?
Is there fluid in your lungs
which is gonna be obstructing
your ability to breathe
and get oxygen from the air
and breathe out carbon dioxide
that your body's producing?
So we're gonna take them when
the monkey should be healthy,
when we think it might be sick,
and then when we're interested to see
whether it's sick or healthy,
because we want to see
if it's an immune system
remembered the virus.
And then the last thing we can do
is what's known as histopathology.
And histopathology basically
just means looking at the monkey's lung
under the microscope.
Having a in-detailed look at
the microscopic cellular level,
what's going on?
Does the monkeys long look healthy
or does it not look healthy?
Does it look like the
monkey has got the disease
or does it look like the
monkey is in the clear
and it's pretty healthy?
So those are the experiments,
I'm gonna be taking you through,
those four different areas;
looking for swabs of the
virus, looking at antibodies
to see if the monkeys
mounting an immune response
to the virus,
looking at x-rays to see
how the monkey's chest looks
and looking at histopathology,
looking at the monkeys
lungs under the microscope
to see whether they look healthy.
Okay, so if that's what they
did, what did they find?
What did the authors show?
So before I show you the data on swabs,
I just wanna explain to you
how it's gonna be displayed.
They're gonna be showed on these graphs.
I'm sorry about the quality of the graphs,
they're not wonderful.
That's not my fault, it's
the fault of the authors.
Unfortunately in the published work
the graphs are not fantastic quality.
But along the bottom we're
looking at days post infection,
so the number of days that
have elapsed since exposure
or re-exposure to the
virus in the case of DPR,
which would be days post reinfection.
And then along the side,
we're looking at viral
loads in nasal swaps.
And what that really just
means is the amount of virus
that we detected on the swabs
that we took from the monkey's nose.
I should point out that,
along the side is actually
a logarithmic scale.
And you might be familiar with this,
with something like the Richter scale,
which is used to measure
how strong earthquakes are.
Basically what it means
is as you go up the scale,
the distances between
the numbers increases.
So the distance between one on this scale
and two is actually only one
10th as big as the distance
between two and three and so on and so on.
So really all that means
is if you move up on a logarithmic scale,
you're getting a lot
bigger, a lot more quickly.
It's just a way that we
use of displaying data
so that really big points don't
block out really small ones.
Cool.
Okay, so that's taking through the graph.
So let's look at the graphs.
So I'm splitting the monkeys
here into two groups.
Monkeys zero, one and two,
and I'm displaying the data
about their swabs on the bottom left
and then the other group is
monkeys three, four, five
and six which I'm
displaying in the middle.
And the monkeys zero, one and two
are the monkeys we just infected once.
So these monkeys are not
going to be reinfected
whereas monkey three, four, five and six,
we're going to attempt to reinfect them,
we're gonna see what happens.
So in both cases, after we
initially infect the monkeys,
at day zero, you can see
we don't detect virus
in the nose of the monkeys.
And then unsurprisingly,
we see this big increase
in the amount of virus
that's being detected in the
swabs from the monkey's nose.
That's totally consistent
with the monkeys getting sick,
the virus is replicating
inside the monkeys respiratory tract,
and you can pick it up
in swabs of the nose.
And then also on a surprisingly,
the virus is reduced around
day 10 post infection.
You can see that the monkey
has successfully fought the
virus off, it looks like, right?
'Cause we're not detecting virus
in the monkey's nose anymore.
It looks like all the virus
has been killed by the monkey.
So what's gonna happen
when we attempt to reinfect the monkey?
Well, let's have a look.
So at 28 days post reinfection,
if you look at the middle here,
that dotted line represents the point
at which we re-exposed
the monkeys to the virus.
And what you can see, quite remarkably,
is that there's absolutely no increase
in the amount of virus
detected in these monkeys,
monkeys, three, four, five and six,
that is after the re-exposure.
And that's in stark contrast
to what happened
the first time we exposed
the monkeys to the virus
where you saw this big spike
in the amount of virus that was detected.
Now on the right here,
what I'm showing you
is the comparisons of the reinfection,
amount of virus detected
and the initial infection
at specific days.
So, you'll see the first
two bars refer to day zero,
the second two to day
five, day seven, day 14,
post either infection or reinfection.
And the blue dot represents the bar,
which is in the initial
infection situation
and the orange dot represents the bar
in the reinfection situation.
Now, the reason in the first
two you can't see any bars
is because they didn't detect
any virus at this point.
And then at day five, you
can see under the blue dot,
there is virus detected in the
initial infection situation.
But in the reinfection situation,
there's no virus detected.
Same as to at day seven and
day 14, there's no difference
because under both situations
there's no virus detected at this point.
The monkeys who were initially infected,
by day 14 have successfully
cleared the virus
out of their system and
so you can't find it.
So interestingly, this is also replicated,
I say interestingly, it's
pretty unsurprising actually,
it's also replicated if you
swab the monkey in other places.
If you take a swab from
the monkey's throat
or a swab from the monkey's anus,
both of which are places that
we'd expect to find virus
during an active infection.
And you can see that what's happening here
is the monkey initially,
will see a spike in a virus
detected by the swabs,
but when we reinfect them
in the central two panels,
you can see that there's no virus detected
after we reinfect the monkey
or we attempt to reinfect the monkey.
So collectively I think this
should give you a picture
that after we initially infect the monkey,
it looks like there's virus being produced
and we can pick it up in
swabs of the monkey's nose
and the monkey's throat.
But if we allow the monkey to recover
and then re-expose it 28 days
after the initial exposure,
we can't see virus replicating,
which suggests that the monkey
is successfully fighting the virus off
and preventing it from replicating
and establishing an infection.
Cool.
So we've talked about the
first one of my four measures.
Now let's talk about the second one,
which is looking at antibodies.
Okay, so we're looking at antibodies
at various different points
along the progression of this experiment.
And what you can see here is again,
I'm talking about monkey
zero, one and two.
These are the monkeys that
were infected only once
at the beginning, at day zero.
And you can see that, excuse
me, as the experiment moves on,
there is this little lag
where the monkeys are trying
to generate the antibodies.
That's the gap in the plots
I was showing you earlier,
the monkey's immune system is
looking for the right antibody
to fight this virus off.
Looking, looking, looking,
searching, it finds it,
and then you can see it produced,
beginning around day 14,
and then into date, 21 and 28.
And you can see relatively high levels
of the antibodies present.
So what about in the situation
where we reinfect the monkey?
Well, what you can see is
the first half of this graph
is basically the same.
We initially infected the monkey,
you can see it's looking
for the antibody looking,
looking, looking, looking,
it finds it around day 14,
we get production of the antibody.
And then around day 28 when
we reinfect these monkeys,
you can see that they then
kick into a higher gear.
They're producing even more antibodies
and there's this enormous peak
at day 42 post initial infection,
which is 14 days after
the second infection.
And the antibody levels at
that point are much higher
than they were 14 days
after the first infection.
And that's what's
spotted on the far right,
you can see 14 days
post initial infection,
you've got some antibody produced,
but 14 days post reinfection,
you have even more antibody produced.
Which suggests, I mean, that backs up
what I was telling you earlier
about the idea of the immune
response kicking in quicker
and more punchy, it's being more effective
and more strong the second time around
and that's stopping the
monkey getting sick.
And so for these monkeys don't look like
in terms of the antibodies,
they look like they've mounted
a really effective second
response the second time
you've exposed them
and it looks like that is the basis maybe
of why they're not getting sick.
But so far we haven't
actually taken a look
at what's happening in the monkeys' lungs.
So let's now do that.
So let's look at some x-ray pictures.
We're gonna look at it first
an x-ray picture from day zero.
This is taken before we expose the monkeys
to the virus in the first place.
So this should be a healthy monkey lung.
And you can see,
hopefully down the middle,
you can see the spine of the monkey,
you can see the ribs
coming in from either side
and you can see the monkey's heart
and major blood vessels in the middle.
Now, on x-rays, first of all,
I should say I'm not a radiologist
and people train for a
very long period of time
to look at these x-rays
and be able to interpret them properly.
But what I do know is x-rays of the lungs
should show up in dark
if there's lots of air.
Because it means that the x-rays move
through the lungs more easily
and so that shows up as a
black color on the x-ray.
And so it's good to have
lots of darker color
on your chest x-ray,
because it means that
your lungs are full of air
and that's what they should be full of.
Unfortunately,
it looks like after seven
days post infection,
if you strain your eyes
and look very closely or
if you're a radiologist,
I'm told, you can see there's beginning
to look like some cloudiness.
And that's particularly
pronounced in the red circle
that the authors have kindly
drawn on this x-ray for us.
Now physicians refer to these
as a ground-glass opacit.
And really what they are is
it's the production of fluid
and inflammation in the lung,
which is basically replacing
the air in the lung
and causing the chest
x-ray to look lighter
rather than darker because
it's not moving through air.
Okay, so that's what's happening
when the monkey's sick,
that suggests that the
monkey's developing pneumonia
when it's sick.
Again, that's not surprising,
that's what happens with
a respiratory infection
like SARS-CoV-2.
So let's look at what happens
when the monkey gets better at day 28,
immediately before we re-challenge it
with a new specimen of the virus.
So what you can see here is
in the blue shaded circle,
the lung looks clearer here, doesn't it?
So we can see less cloudiness,
it looks like there's no
fluid appearing in the lungs,
suggesting the monkey has
got rid of the pneumonia
it may be had
and it's on the way to
being healthy again.
And then if we look after we reinfect it,
five days after we reinfect the monkey,
that clearness remains on the chest x-ray,
suggesting that monkey
did not develop pneumonia
the second time around.
So the picture we're getting from x-rays
is we initially infected the monkey,
its lungs got filled up with fluid
and it got pneumonia, it recovered.
And when we reinfected the monkey,
it doesn't look like
that pneumonia developed.
It looks like the monkey's lung
remained relatively healthy
and clear and that suggests
it didn't get disease,
it wasn't really sick
the second time around.
So finally, let's have a look
at the monkey's lung itself
under the microscope.
So what I'm showing you here
are two pictures from the monkey's lung.
On top is a sort of zoomed-out version
of the same picture on the bottom
and I've annotated it
to show you two important things in this.
The first is that there's
a lot of white space
on this picture
and that's because there's
a lot of air in the lungs.
That's how it should be,
the lungs are full of air.
They're the organ that does,
that allows oxygen into the blood stream
and excrete CO2 out to the body.
And then we have these thin walls
around the edge of the air sacs.
And you'll have to take my word for it
that those are blood vessels
and they're very thin
and that's important
because it means that the
oxygen in the air sacs
can move very easily into the bloodstream
and the carbon dioxide in the bloodstream
can move very easily into the air sacs
to be excreted and
breathed out of the body.
Cool, so what happens when
we look at some monkey lungs
taken from seven days after
the initial infection?
What do they look like?
Well, it's not a pretty picture.
We've lost a lot of the clear white space
that should appear on the micrograph
and that's indicative of the air sacs
getting much, much smaller
because there's this massive
inflammatory response
in the lung.
We've got much, much thicker
walls of the air sacs,
smaller air sacs and it doesn't
look like a pretty picture.
It looks like this monkey
is gonna be having trouble breathing,
it's certainly not in a healthy place.
And if we compare that to
a similar lung looked at,
but we're now looking after
we reinfected the monkey,
after it's recovered,
and we've reinfected it,
what does it look like?
Well, it's a much, much
better looking lung.
We've still got nice big air sacks,
maybe it looks a little bit different,
it looks a little bit more inflamed
and gorged than the control,
but it's certainly a
hell of a lot healthier
than the lung in the middle.
So if we combine this with the x-ray,
the picture we're getting is healthy lungs
at the beginning after
initially infecting the monkey,
the monkey's lungs
unfortunately become diseased
and we get inflammation,
the air sacs gets washed out.
And so this lung isn't working so well.
We allow the monkey to
recover, we reinfect it
and the lungs don't look
bad when they're reinfected.
They look basically normal
and basically quite healthy.
So collectively then I think the authors
have pretty convincingly shown
that monkeys do not get
reinfected by SARS-CoV-2
after a second exposure,
four weeks after the first infection.
And we know that because
when we exposed the monkeys,
we don't detect virus in swabs
from the monkeys' noses and throats,
we don't detect pneumonia in the x-rays
taken of the monkeys lungs,
and the monkeys lungs look
healthy under the microscope.
Cool.
So that's what the authors have shown.
How does that fit in
with what we already know
and what questions remain outstanding?
Well, I think the most important question
that remains outstanding
is to do with timing.
And this is a really
difficult question to answer.
It's not that scientists haven't tried
to answer this question
or don't have good
experiments for addressing it,
it's just it's very difficult
to do these experiments.
Ideally, we'd like to know,
if we infected a monkey
three or four years ago
or five or 10 or 15 or 20 years ago,
and we re expose it to the
same virus, does it get sick?
We'd like to do this
experiment with a time gap
not a four weeks, but of
four years or four decades
to understand how long
the immunity is lasting,
how long is that memory lasting?
But of course, that's not possible
with a virus like COVID-19,
which has emerged in the past six months.
That we didn't know that this
virus existed five years ago,
we couldn't have been infecting monkeys
to do these experiments five years ago
because we didn't know
that the virus existed.
So we're severely limited in
our ability to look backwards,
to enable us to do these experiments
to address how long immunity really lasts.
But we do have an important
data point from this experiment,
which suggests that at the very least,
your immune system is capable
or the monkey's immune system,
which is extremely similar to yours,
is capable of remembering
an infection, full stop.
And then there's a second question
to do with whether immunity
is gonna last in its entirety
or whether it might be
remembered in some degree.
So even if immunity expires fully,
are you protected by some degree,
by the memory that you have?
So even if you get sick the second time,
is it possible that you
get sick less severely
than you got sick the first
time you got infected?
Because these memories are not a binary,
yes, you remembered, no
you didn't remember thing,
there's a continuum.
And then of course we need to think
about the public health
considerations of this.
If we do develop a vaccine,
are people gonna need regular
treatment with this vaccine
or are they gonna be able
to be vaccinated just once?
And can we use a measure
like antibody levels
to predict whether someone
needs to be vaccinated or not?
Cool.
So if you weren't listening
to anything I just said
over the last 40 minutes, what's
the answer to the question,
can I get COVID-19 twice?
Well, what I would say is
this, in the short term
it's extremely unlikely.
We've seen that from the
monkey over a period of months,
it's unlikely that your immune
system is gonna forget it,
the monkey's immune
system certainly did not.
But, we're not sure about
when immunity might expire
in the medium term or the long term
because we haven't been able
to do this experiments yet.
We we didn't know this virus existed
more than six months ago.
And if we look to the best evidence
that we can speculate with,
it would come from looking at viruses,
which are similar to SARS-CoV-2
like the original SARS virus
and MERS, middle East
Respiratory Syndrome.
If we look at those
viruses, we have some data.
It's not foolproof and
it's not a comprehensive,
but we have some data suggesting
that immunity lasts
around two to four years
for these related corona viruses.
So it wouldn't surprise me if
it was a similar time length
with this virus, but we don't know.
It is different, it's a different virus
and it could be longer,
it could be shorter.
That remains for scientists to establish.
Rest assured, there's lots
of people pretty hard at work
on this problem.
So that's it from me.
I'd just like to say a big thank you
to the whole of the D4P team
from all over the world and the US,
and invite questions from any of you guys
if my talk has formed them.
So thank you very much.